gas prices are through the roof the
national average for a gallon of gas is
now three dollars and seventy three
cents according to data collected by
triple a for the first time ever average
gas prices have surpassed five dollars
per gallon in multiple american cities
san francisco los angeles napa san luis
obispo couple others as well
oil spiked to more than 116 dollars per
barrel earlier this week the highest
it's been since 2008 and that number is
only poised to go up as the war in
ukraine a war largely of joe biden's own
making
rages on and disrupts global oil
supplies so what does the white house
plan to do to give americans relief at
the pump
why
buy oil from russia of course
during that those years where it would
you know take to bring down prices as
you're saying we should just continue to
buy russian oil
well again jackie i think you're
familiar with a number of steps we've
taken a historic release from the
strategic petroleum reserve
well we can well let me finish what we
can do over time and what this is all a
remain reminder of in the president's
view is our need to reduce our reliance
on oil the europeans need to do that we
need to do that if we do more to invest
in clean energy more to invest in other
sources of energy that's exactly what we
can do to prevent this from happening in
the future we welcome any republicans
from joining us in that effort go ahead
as long as we're buying russian oil
though aren't we financing the war
well jackie again uh it's only about 10
percent of what we're importing
i've not made any announcement about any
decision on that front but our objective
here and our focus is making sure that
any step we take maximizes the impact on
president putin and minimizes it on the
american people
so just to recap
russia invaded ukraine because joe biden
gave the go-ahead to putin's nordstrom 2
oil pipeline which gives russia direct
access to the european oil market and
took away all of ukraine's leverage
conservatives knew this would happen and
have been talking about it
for years for years
ted cruz warned that this would happen
and he successfully got sanctions placed
on the pipeline under the trump
administration during which time putin
did not invade ukraine until biden took
office and removed the sanctions at
which point putin did invade ukraine
even the liberal new york magazine
admits that this is true that biden's
green light of the pipeline led to the
invasion which by the way biden himself
literally encouraged when he assured
russia that america wouldn't retaliate
against any invasion if it were only a
quote unquote minor incursion so
russia invaded ukraine because biden
gave the go-ahead on the russia oil
pipeline at the same time biden shut
down american oil pipelines in the name
of fighting climate change apparently
russian oil doesn't harm the climate
russian oil doesn't anger the sun gods
like american oil does now
americans are still consuming the same
amount of oil so the only practical
effect of crippling the american energy
industry is that now we need to import
the oil from overseas including from our
enemies including from russia which
relies on oil exports to fund the war in
ukraine which means that joe biden's
stupid energy policy not only started
the war in ukraine but is currently
funding it with your taxpayer dollars
dollars that you now need to stretch
because his stupid energy policy is also
emptying out your wallet at the pump i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday is from
louie shamilton who says i'm starting to
feel bad for michael he keeps having to
say i told you so
it has to be taking a toll on him it is
look at me
i'm exhausted
i'm i'm i'm worn out
from being this right i am
as donald trump said sick and tired of
winning i'm winning on the predictions
we're not winning politically we're
losing politically because of bad
leadership
in washington we go you got to do
whatever you can in these difficult days
to protect yourself notably to protect
your identity which is why you got to
check out lifelock head to lifelock.com
knowles tax time is always stressful but
this stress can magnify if an identity
thief steals your info files a bogus
return
and pockets your refund the irs
recommends electronic filing and using
their pin tool for extra security other
safety tips include looking out for
phishing scams checking your financial
accounts regularly for unusual activity
and setting up two-factor authentication
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet not just during tax
season every single day in an instant a
cyber criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your reputation good thing
there's lifelock lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats like your
social security number for sale on the
dark web i love lifelock it makes me
feel much more secure if they find out
your info has potentially been
compromised they've got a specialist on
board ready to go if you become a victim
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses you can help protect what's
yours with lifelock by norton join now
save up to 25 off your first year
lifelock.com
knowles that is lifelock.com k-n-w-l-e-s
for 25 off that's their answer
their answer to the american oil and gas
problem is
buy it from overseas
including from our enemies
we didn't we didn't need to buy it from
overseas we didn't need to buy it from
our enemies
we could just make it ourselves that's
what we were doing
things were looking great on the energy
front during the trump years
and then the libs voluntarily shut down
american energy
and they did so because they said that
if we continue to produce energy and
really to consume energy then we're
going to harm the environment and get
the sun gods really angry at us and
they're going to
shower us with all sorts of plagues to
punish us for the sin of driving
automobiles so they they attack the
american energy industry they go after
coal they go after gas they go after oil
but the thing is we still need all that
stuff
so nothing changed in terms of what
we're emitting and and polluting and
driving and moving around we just
instead of making it ourselves we now
import it at a premium from overseas
including from our enemies who are using
that money then to fund wars that oppose
american interests
and they're not just talking about
they're not just talking about buying
oil from russia which we're doing i love
gensake she says no no don't worry it's
only 10 of our oil imports
10
of the american oil imports are coming
from this country that relies almost
exclusively on energy to fund its
imperial wars that we're now also kind
of fighting in are you kidding me
oh good it's okay i was worried it was
15 okay it's 10 though that's fine
they're not just talking about russia
they're now talking about buying oil
from iran there was a some left winger
blue check named ryan cooper tweeted out
quote
iran has 103 million barrels of oil
loaded up on tankers and ready to go
cc joe biden
as if to say look look we don't do
business with state sponsors of terror
and
and people who chain death to america
yeah well but they got the oil ready to
go
and iranian oil doesn't cause climate
change it's it's got the magic of the
russian oil they've got magic genies
over there in the middle east and the
magic iranian oil that doesn't have
carbon emissions only the american
domestically produced oil does okay it's
not just ryan it's not just these random
leftist blue checks who are trying to
buy oil from our enemies
and pete butterjudge our our
transportation secretary i think he's
back from paternity leave his c-section
scar has healed up very nicely and the
energy secretary or the transportation
secretary rather is is back at work he
he goes on to msnbc he's asked about
what we're going to do to give relief to
people at the pump and he says look all
options
are on the table but we don't want to be
too hasty we don't want any permanent
solutions could the president possibly
consider authorizing the keystone
pipeline uh working something out with
iran i mean look the the president has
said that all options are on the table
but we also need to make sure that
we're not galloping after permanent
solutions to immediate short-term
problems where
more strategic and tactical actions in
the short term can make a difference
so he says yeah maybe we'll okay
keystone except the white house already
shut that down they said no keystone
pipeline that's going to take too long
to build in america so that's off the
table and he says what about buying from
iran yeah that's on the table
okay i'm not surprised when democrats
want to buy oil from our enemies what
does surprise me though is that second
part the philosophical part that buddha
judge put in there
because buddha just say what you will
about him he's a fairly intelligent guy
he's got all the credentials checks all
the boxes
brain brand name school rather worked at
mckinsey very polished right he's got he
knows all the hip cool lingo that all
the elites are using
but then he says
we don't we don't want to find a
permanent solution
to short-term problems
uh
why not
so first of all the energy issue is not
a short-term problem it is exacerbated
at different periods sometimes it's a
lot worse than at other times right now
with war breaking out in europe yeah
it's pretty bad
but it's a it's a problem generally we
don't want to be reliant on our enemies
for our energy consumption
why wouldn't we want a permanent
solution i want a permanent solution
give me oh here's a permanent solution
produce american energy
and what the bootage edges of the world
and the gensakes of the world and the
joe bidens of the world what they say is
well that's what we're going to do
but we're not going to do it from coal
and we're not going to do it from oil
and we're not going to do it from gas
and we're not going to do it from
nuclear for some reason so we're going
to do it from
windmills
we're going to do it from solar
we're going to do it from
from the hopes and dreams of unicorns
prancing around the plains that's where
we're going to get our energy from we're
going to get american energy for the
world superpower for now for a country
of 330 million people with effectively a
global empire for now we're going to get
energy
from
windmills
but you're not you're not that's never
going to happen the so-called green
sources of energy are extraordinarily
inefficient they're extraordinarily
ineffective they're also not great for
the environment by the way that's the
that's the secret i forget the
comedian's name there's a comedian many
years ago
who made the point he said okay you're
all switching from gas cars to to
electric cars
uh do you know where electricity comes
from it doesn't come from magic okay it
comes from dirty filthy energy sources
and even even so the production the
batteries is very bad for the
environment even so it's not
that's not an answer so really what the
answer is is we don't have an answer
the answer is uh shrug your shoulders we
don't want a permanent solution we're
just going to keep buying oil from our
enemies we're just going to move from
crisis to crisis to crisis then we're
going to create some more crises and
then we're going to respond to the
crises that in many cases we created
and we're just going to keep doing that
and keep everyone on the edge of their
seats
at our beck and call
in perpetuity that is
the democrat
liberal
way
of governing
not a good way to govern this is these
are these people who are working for the
administration they are not the best
they are not the brightest they are not
very competent when you want bright
competent people for your organization i
strongly recommend you check out
ziprecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles i think it's great to learn new
skills i'm always trying to keep my mind
active become more useful i'd love to
learn how to save more money
i'd love to learn how to own a plant
without killing it i haven't perfected
that yet but i will try
i love learning new things just like
ziprecruiter their ai is always learning
so if you're hiring their ai gets better
and faster at finding the right
candidates for all of your roles right
now you can try it for free at zip
recruiter.com
knowles zip recruiter uses this powerful
matching technology to find and match
the right candidates with your job it's
not just spaghetti at the wall it
proactively presents these candidates to
you then you find your favorites zip
recruiter will go invite them to apply
makes the whole process much faster
smoother saves you time saves you money
most important investment is your
personnel right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
one of the
many unique aspects of this war in
ukraine as i have noted and gotten in
trouble for noting this is the first
major war to break out in my lifetime
between civilized nations that's why
it's a little different than the various
minor conflicts and wars of empire that
we've seen around the world in the last
quarter century
one of the
strange things about this war
is
military maneuvers matter and i think we
forget that
because the wars have been
for instance the war in afghanistan the
united states the world superpower goes
into
a backwater of
largely illiterate goat herders i really
don't mean to be offensive but we're
talking about asymmetries of power here
that are basically
unimaginable
and we just dominate it we conquer
afghanistan in five seconds and then
politically speaking we don't know what
to do with it we don't know whether to
hold it we don't know whether to make it
in imperial territory we don't know
whether to try to prop up some fake
afghan army and and and government
that's really just a client state for
the united states and then we've got a
lot of domestic political pressure to
pull out and we just voluntarily give up
the thing it's not as though they were
the the afghanis the taliban were
actually going to take it back until we
signaled that we're going to pull out
and then they they reconquered it in two
seconds we forget
that
the physical matters
battles places military tactics here
you've got a ukrainian army which is
fighting back reportedly
quite strongly and you've got the
russian army which is not nearly as
strong as
a lot of the world expected it to be and
they're in a little bit of a stalemate
right now i i think that vladimir putin
probably thought this entire military
operation would be over by now would
have been over within 72 hours and it
really hasn't been the russian army
seems to be stuck a little bit
and they're calibrating some of what
they're doing
to not incur too much international
condemnation
now that they've got the condemnation
they seem to be ratcheting up the
attacks and it's really it's a bloody
mess but we hear we hear in the west i
think we these days we don't think that
space and time really matter all that
much we think our bodies don't really
matter that's what transgenderism is we
think the community doesn't really
matter that's why we're all working from
home on our laptops if you're part of
the laptop set
right that's why the ruling elite said
oh who cares about the pandemic you can
all just
telecommute to your consulting job on
your laptop right it's not a big deal no
one needs to be in person that's we're
all we're all going to go live in the
metaverse right we forget no actually
borders matter
land matters people peoples matter
okay this is something our ruling elites
they think that amer america is just an
idea the west it's just kind of an idea
right it's not a people
it's not
institutions it's not
real
rituals and customs and it's all just
kind of floating in the ether man except
it's not
it's not and americans have woken up
against that and this is a a large
backlash against the davos globalist
liberal cosmopolitan
set
we forget that now one update from from
ukraine
that is pretty astonishing it's from
elon musk elon musk is apparently
single-handedly providing internet to
parts of ukraine right now elon musk has
this starling system he's got lots of
satellites up in the sky the satellites
are able to provide internet almost
anywhere and so he's got starlink set up
to provide internet to ukraine so after
the russians went out and hit some
ukrainian telecoms uh starlink is just
providing that and uh musk sent out a
tactical warning he said important
warning starlink is the only non-russian
communication system still working in
some parts of ukraine so probability of
being targeted is high please use it
with caution turn on starlink only when
needed and place the antenna away as far
away from people as possible place light
camouflage over the antenna to avoid
visual detection
because that it's not everything just
turns on with the flip of a switch in
the smart in the smart world
tactics matter placement matters
geography matters that's what's playing
out and it's it's shocking the world
we are we are seeing the collapse of the
post-cold war order of relative peace
and stability at least in
the civilized world at least in the
western world it's all set it's all good
no more big wars we're just gonna have
wars of empire well
not so much
and
if if the bidens of the world are in
charge if the liberal establishment that
led us to this point is in charge we are
headed
in a very different direction and we are
we are headed for much more conflict
much more strife a place in which
traditional nationhood
and tactics and militaries are going to
matter some good news from overseas
better news from overseas is france is
suspending its covid
passport
france has just said emmanuel macron who
is the liberal technic rat who runs
france he said that now even though the
the passport was only introduced in in
uh january uh the pass system
uh
is now going to be done away with uh the
the vaccine pass system dates back a
little earlier it had been floated
it actually first went into effect on
the last day that i was in
paris
last year
so the implementation kind of got
stalled and muddled and paused and
rolled out but so when it first went
into effect i actually didn't know if i
was going to be able to go to france
because
you were going to have to show your show
your medical papers basically anywhere
you went and then they delayed it
delayed they delayed it the the first
day it went into effect was as i was
flying back out of france and a lot of
people said why do you want to go to
france those crazy french they just
they're so coveted nuts they're all
afraid they're neurotic about it they're
that's not true
the french government was neurotic about
it the french people were not the french
people were chiller about kovid than
most american people i talked to
certainly in the big cities
the parisians they didn't care
i'd get into a cab i'd say do i have to
wear the stupid mask they'd say well no
that's why i have the vaccine i am
vaccinated i don't care you do whatever
you want i do not need
i pepe le pew is for my drivers actually
in paris uh no the the french people
were pretty normal about it there was a
big gulf just like we see here in
america
frankly perhaps even more so there's a
big gulf between the french people
and the government the government's
finally waking up to this and they're
saying okay no more show me your papers
when you try to go get a croissant in
paris
you're seeing this spread throughout the
west the the west's
ruling class by which i don't just mean
whatever party happens to be in power
but i mean the whole edifice you know we
talk about the deep state the
transnational international institutions
they're losing their grip on the common
sense and they're losing their grip on
power and a lot of what you're seeing
happening right now in eastern europe is
a reflection of that
there's a huge chasm between the elites
and the people specifically over this
issue that i was just talking about this
issue of
nations being real places with real
borders and
borders really do matter and people
fight over borders by the way and there
are wars over borders and there are wars
between peoples who view themselves
distinctly with different language and
different customs and not everyone is
just replaceable okay not everyone you
it's not just that you can swap out the
people of one country and replace them
with a totally different people and it's
gonna be the same country okay but that
is what
elites in our country have been
experimenting with for a long time
elites in the democrat and republican
parties this is the effect of mass
migration
mass migration
over the past 60 years or so we've seen
what 60 million some odd people
move from other parts of the world into
the united states this is the largest
this is the largest mass migration of
people
ever
ever in the history of the world
last year was three million immigrants
came into america
two million illegal immigrants came into
america last year just last year
just in the first year under joe biden
sometimes the libs they they get upset
they talk about the great replacement
conspiracy theory which is uh heinous
white supremacist neo-nazi conspiracy
theory well what's the theories the
theory is that
liberals are using mass migration as a
political tool to alter the voting
demographics in a country in their favor
that's
not only is that obviously true but the
liberals have been bragging about this
for 10 years
so they're doing it they're saying
they're doing it and then they're
telling you that you're not allowed to
say that they already told you that
they're doing it
and it's not just democrats
i've got here a letter
to nancy pelosi to schumer to mccarthy
the republican leader to mitch mcconnell
calling for
more migration
the alliance for a new immigration
consensus and who signs it you got a
bunch of lib groups that sign it sure
but then you've you've got the george w
bush
institute
you've got
coke-backed enterprise the kochs were
the koch brothers were a big force
behind the tea party they're usually
considered more on the right but they
they do support mass migration you've
got the u.s chamber of commerce used to
be sort of right-wing now it's really
more considered firmly on on the left
lots of different groups signing on to
this
according to the last gallup poll
only nine percent of americans say they
want more immigration
nine percent of americans
according to that poll 35 percent said
they want less immigration total there
have been other polls there was a
harvard-harris poll now four five years
ago
showed that the when you actually get
down into numbers on immigration the
vast majority of americans want to
drastically reduce all immigration legal
and illegal
and yet the elites from both parties
want to increase it that is wrong it's
wrong to do that first of all it's wrong
to flood a country with foreigners
against the will of the people
especially in a self-government where
the people are supposed to rule and
where
citizens can vote and those votes
determine who rules that's wrong that's
wrong to do and it's completely tone
deaf
i think kevin mccarthy has finally
realized this is no good he said that
the chamber of commerce is no longer a
republican group
it's firmly on the left we need to get
that right ourselves if the
people who are backing this sort of
thing
the elites
they're not on our team okay the people
are on our team if we're going to have a
team at all it's got to be a team with
the people
he who pays the piper calls the tune
or should this is a general rule of
politics
this is
why we get so worried when we find out
that corrupt ukrainian
energy companies are paying off members
of the biden family or the clinton
foundation we get a little worried
because
that implies a certain degree of
corruption
when people when when individual donors
make huge donations then they start
making demands of politicians that's why
we have laws about donations in politics
and when
people who want mass migration are the
ones paying for all the conservative
activities
what's going to happen those
conservatives are going to go soft on
immigration that's what happened for
decades
and decades now there's only one area
where
he who pays the piper has not been able
to call the tune and that would be an
immigration or an education rather
we pay for the education system we the
taxpayers pay for the education system
it is administered by the state in most
cases
and yet even when it's conservatives
who are voting and paying and
administrating administering
for some reason the left dominates these
schools and we've got to stop that
there's great news that came out of
wyoming
a uh
the wyoming senate just passed an
amendment to the state budget that would
defund the university of wyoming's
gender and women's studies program
this amendment will be sent to the house
for approval republican state senator
sherry steinmetz was responsible for
this good on you sherry this is awesome
the wyoming republicans should totally
get behind this is this cancel culture
sort of but as we've said in the past
cancel culture is a wonderful thing when
it's applied to cancel that which is
false and ugly and evil we want all
societies cancel all all societies have
taboos and things that are in standards
and things that are off limits that's
inevitable that's always going to be the
case the question is what is off-limits
what's bad what do we ostracize what do
we censor what do we cancel
and conservatives have adopted this kind
of neutral sounding language of oh i'm
for all ideas i'm for don't sense or
anything but it's bs it's not true it's
that is language from the left in the
1960s which they they too knew was
instrumental and not real the minute
they got power they implemented their
own standards we would too that's just
the nature of politics okay and so when
you look at a
department like women's and gender
studies
really all of the critical studies
departments you realize this is not
about a classical liberal education this
is about radical political
indoctrination it's really bad we
shouldn't be paying for it it should it
has no place at a university and you got
to cancel it and you got to kick it out
speaking of cancelling teachers there's
a fourth grade teacher in indiana who
was just exposed for owning a satanic
temple
fourth grade teacher
teaching little nine-year-olds
is a practicing
high level
satanist
now look i'm tolerant you know i'm a
tolerant guy and everything and we
should be tolerant no but
i think that's a little too far i think
the satanists teaching your
nine-year-old that's too much
but michael some people would say what
about freedom of religion
uh
that's not what freedom of religion
means okay
freedom
first of all freedom of religion as we
understand it is really refers to the
first amendment which says that the
federal government will not have an
established church
okay that's a very different thing from
saying satanists can teach your
nine-year-olds
right and frankly one of the reasons
that there was no state established
church at the federal level is because
there were established churches at the
state level for decades after the
constitution was ratified i don't think
the founding fathers
if they found out that their words and
documents were being used to defend
satanists teaching nine nine-year-olds i
don't think that they would applaud this
as some wonderful blessing of liberty
you know hold a parade for this woman uh
probably they wouldn't even argue about
it they would be too busy gathering
kindling to burn her at the stake okay
this is not the sort of thing that is
acceptable
and the school's defending her they say
we do not ask our teachers or any
employees about their religious beliefs
well yeah but if you're worshiping the
dark lord of the underworld that's a
little bit too far okay
religious liberty 2 has limits
i'll give you an example of this
if if a teacher at a
certainly at an elementary school but
even at a college were found to be a
nazi
that teacher would be fired in two
seconds and everyone would support it
well what does it mean to be a nazi
it means you hold certain political
views i guess but those views are a
little deeper than just politics right
they're kind of cultural
they're actually kind of religious
they're views about the nature of man
and the nature of races and
the
the human dignity and worth of different
races
nazism when you really follow it down to
its
bottom has a deeply occult element to it
all of the leading nazis were practicing
some to some degree paganism or occult
rituals
it's religious because you at bottom all
politics is religious okay
we have in the last few decades got into
a place where we will tolerate satanists
teaching our kids i won't i won't do
that i will not send my kid to be
instructed by satanists i will not send
my taxpayer dollars if i have any say of
it to to have satanists teach our kids
this is a wonderful use
of the political power of parents
to
shape their students education
before we go i do want to get to katangi
brown jackson i've been meaning to get
to her all week and we just haven't had
time to do it she is the biden supreme
court
uh nominee
uh
the reason i want to call her to your
attention we'll go more into her next
week
but she's a formidable supreme court
nominee okay i don't think we can just
people were going to write her off as a
diversity hire because joe biden said
she was going to be a diversity hire but
this is a this is a bright woman and
she's very very clever she's a double
harvard person harvard undergraduate at
harvard law school not that that's
necessarily a recommendation these days
but at least it used to be
she was a judge on the u.s district
court for d.c and the court of appeals
for dc she was put on the court of
appeals for dc one year ago less than
one year ago
she's big big lib
she's had her decisions reversed even by
left-wing courts
but
she
she's very clever
she had an exchange with senator ted
cruz again maybe we'll be able to get to
the clips of this
uh next week maybe maybe not we'll see
we'll see how we'll see how well you
behave over the weekend maybe we'll try
to get to that but what she
what she said here she was asked do you
believe there's a living constitution
like all the liberals do or do you
believe the constitution means what it
says it means and she was able to evade
the question she told senator cruz well
you know look i haven't had to make any
decisions in that regard in the lower
courts and she said well i believe the
constitution's an enduring document she
did very well
she did very well she's a very
convincing candidate i doubt that
republicans are going to be able to
shoot down her nomination on the one
hand i guess you want intelligent people
on the supreme court on the other hand i
don't know that i want
a very intelligent liberal radical judge
on the supreme court and in many ways a
dumber liberal judge would be better
because it would easily be easier to
undermine that sort of person's
jurisprudence it's not just the
intelligence we're after it's where you
want it aimed what it kind of gets back
to what we were talking about you want
that intelligence used for good things
that are edifying that will build up the
country
some some of the greatest saints in
history could have been the worst
sinners in the world such as the the
power that they've got the question is
how do you use that power for good or
for evil
mark your calendars folks march 10th the
premiere of our latest film the
hyperions is
out
it's not woke doesn't have any
underlying
pedantic political message it's just an
excellent film when it comes to
entertainment that's really what we're
after check out the trailer
good day hyperion club members
[Music]
[Applause]
we've come for one
thing our titan badges this titan badge
can grant an individual superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
on my way
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
we will be streaming the film once and
for all
on march 10th for everybody on youtube
but then that's it for everybody that's
the last time we're going to premiere
that movie
on youtube so be sure if you want to
watch the movie after that that you head
on over to daily wire's youtube channel
and then head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe so you can become a member
watch that movie our whole growing cache
of content that we've got to offer also
we've got a great book coming out with
jonathan isaac
terrific patriotic basketball player
really nice guy uh go pre-order that
today it's it's on his political stances
his career his his religious beliefs the
book is why i stand it's available for
preroad amazon reserve your copy today
we will be right back with the mailbag
welcome back my absolute favorite time
of the week when i get to hear from you
answer your pressing questions in the
mailbag
first question up is from miguel ola
miguel he says
hey michael
so i just got into a small debate
recently about abortion and my opponent
brought up a very good point that has
caused me to lose the debate overall
okay
it's very complicated and with a lot of
nuance and such but simply put with the
non-religious view of the world and
humanity there is no way to justify
intrinsic human value or even objective
morality i tried going through all the
small nuances like asking when a human
has value or where morality stems from
and he had an answer for everything he
said that the way he sees it the fetus
becomes valuable enough not to kill once
it has received sentience and in the
case of someone not being sentient
uh they had previous sentience so they
do still have value how do i a christian
debunk this view in a secular sense it's
hard to debunk it because it's so stupid
and incoherent it doesn't
the first part that he said is is
coherent and so i guess that's where i
would begin
he said that
or you said maybe summarizing his point
that
you know if the world were such that god
did not exist and morality does not
exist and you know if reality were
completely different than it is then you
couldn't say that human beings have
value and so you couldn't argue against
abortion that's true
so in that world in that bizarro world
that is not real
not the world that we actually live in
that's true you couldn't argue against
abortion you also couldn't argue against
murder laws
and you also couldn't argue or are you
for murder laws rather and you couldn't
argue for laws against armed robbery and
you couldn't order it all are you at all
actually because the world would not
have logic and so it would not have
meaning or truth and you couldn't convey
anything to anyone else
so that would that would be difficult to
make any sort of argument at all now
your friend has said that he believes
that human life gets value
when it becomes sentient
and he believes this because
why does he believe that what's his
he would have to make an argument for
that
you're saying that he made the argument
that uh you know you shouldn't kill
people in a coma for instance because
they were previously sentient but
but now they're not but because they
were previously sentient you shouldn't
kill them because why because he says so
well okay but you need to make an
argument as to why
human life becomes valuable with
sentience that is not self-evident
he's just stating that as a premise and
then coming to a conclusion from his own
premise but speaking of premises
sometimes people ask me this
they say michael i want you can you make
a totally secular atheist argument
for
pro-life or for anything else i say well
uh
no
why or even if i could i mean you can't
really make a atheist argument for
anything because
because the very
fact that our language has meaning
implies that god exists but
moreover why would i
well why would i why would i make an
argument
from the basis of my opponent's
wrong premises that would seem to be a
very foolish thing to do
but we've we say this on the show all
the time
all human conflict ultimately is
theological so you are going to have to
get down to first principles and if his
first principle is that god doesn't
exist and human life doesn't have any
value and i'm just going to say
completely arbitrarily that life that i
value life that is sentient but not but
and then some life that's not sentient
when i feel like it well okay then i
guess that's that
but the premise is off we do life does
have value human beings do have value
there is a moral order the fact that we
have civil laws and that we recognize
that it's wrong to commit murder and
wrong to commit armed robbery and wrong
to kill babies when we're being honest
with ourselves the reason we recognize
that is because we there is objective
truth in a moral order we have faculties
of reason and moral conscience that
allow us to make some sense of that and
we are valuable creatures made in the
image of god that's why
and so if you say well make an argument
but without any of those beliefs well
i'm sorry you're out you know if if my
aunt had cajones she'd be my uncle you
know if wishes were horses beggars would
ride if i had some ham i'd have a ham
sandwich if i had some bread you get the
picture if i had if if ifs and butts
were candy and that's we'd all have a
merry christmas but the premises are
wrong and so you should begin with
correct
premises always from alex dear michael
i'm a freshman in high school and i love
the show thank you i'm having some love
troubles and i'm looking for advice i
went to a school dance recently and was
flirting with a girl who i like we were
already friends after the fact i found
out that she already has a boyfriend but
she was still being perfectly amicable
toward me so i wanted to ask where do i
go from here i don't know how to proceed
because i really like this girl but want
to respect her relationship thanks for
the advice
just because there is a goalie my friend
does not mean you cannot score
very important advice now look
if you were in your 20s or 30s
if this girl that you had a crush on
were married i would say back off
respect the marriage
you're 14 years old
this girl presumably is a teenager as
well
she's got a little teenage fling
and she's obviously thinks you're
attractive
make it happen buster
when you know sweet little elise and i
were high school sweethearts we've known
each other since we were 10 or 11 years
old and
when i was in
i think we were in eighth grade sweet
little least had a crush on me but i had
a different girlfriend
who was she was very upset
when we were in ninth grade i had a big
crush on her she had another boyfriend i
was very jealous i was very angry i
thought oh no this is awful this is but
you know you just kind of you stick
around you maybe put on your to quote
the former italian prime minister silvio
berlusconi you put on that the playboy
charm you know you you chatter up don't
do anything immoral but you know
chatter up maybe be a little flirtatious
the rest is history best of luck
do not you don't need to be overly
scrupulous here my friend the girl is
not married you're in high school
you're she's talking to boys
feel free to uh woo the girl from megan
dear michael i'm a woman in my early 20s
i've been venturing this barren
landscape we call the dating world i
know that you should be yourself when
dating and look for a good man but i'm
curious if there are any major turn-offs
that guys to guys that are easily
avoidable early on while going on dates
with someone would love any advice you
may have
feminism is the one thing i will say
feminism is a major turn off if you're
listening to this show something tells
me that you have not been infected by
that particular disease so i wouldn't
worry too much if if you're worried
about
you know little behaviors that you do or
kind of quirks of your personality don't
don't you don't worry about that too
much one because
women pretending to be someone that
they're not is unattractive all the time
at least if you're looking for a
long-term sort of relationship
uh love affair marriage that sort of
thing
but
but also
you'll be in a situation where you'll go
on a date with a guy and you're going to
be yourself and the guy's just not going
to like you and maybe you're not going
to like him and you're just not going to
click
there are girls that are objectively
gorgeous
that i would not be able to date for
more than two seconds because i would
put a drill in my head it would just be
the personalities just wouldn't clap it
would clash
we're just not made for each other you
know
sweet little elise and i
you know
go together like salt and pepper you
know i don't know we go we go together
very well not only because you know
she's the whole package right she's a
hot foxy lady but also because of her
personality now some guys might not like
her personalities because she's very
funny she's very very uh
shrewd she's very she's got a very
conservative perspective about things
and so that might be a turn off to
people who might want more of a bobble
head or something like that i understand
people are attracted to different things
but i wouldn't try to pretend to be
someone that you're not i don't i don't
think that's going to work for the guys
that wouldn't like the real you and i
don't think they will work for the guys
that would like the real you either from
sam hi michael
as i've gotten older i realized i
struggle with anxiety i don't believe in
taking pills unless it's utterly
necessary and i'm beginning i'm i'm
looking into going to therapy but want
to see if you have any advice on how to
deal with generalized anxiety and
overthinking all the time thanks and
love the show i agree with you i think
pills should be a last resort uh i think
therapy can be a very good thing if you
get a good therapist you know if you get
a therapist who sees the world
in the wrong way who
doesn't recognize certain basic truths
about the world and the human person
then that therapist probably isn't going
to be very good but a good therapist can
be great i mean drew clavin says that
his life was saved by a good therapist
when you get a therapist too also make
sure there's an end date some people go
to their therapist for years and years
and decades and decades and then never
stops and they never get cured make sure
you
there's an end here you know and then
that's it
i do think also
not denying there's certain
physical psychological problems i'm not
denying that there are other
psychological problems that are
more easily treated with therapy but a
lot of what we would call psychological
problems like anxiety can also be
philosophical and ultimately
can be
theological
if you are laboring under
a really confused philosophy and
theology
you i could understand why that would
induce a great deal of anxiety
if you are really struggling with who
you are what your identity is whether
you're going to just turn to worm food
when you die
what the purpose of life is what i mean
that can lead to a great deal of anxiety
i'm not saying that accounts for all or
even a majority of cases of clinical
anxiety but i think it accounts for some
of it and so i would also recommend you
try to treat the philosophical
and
theological aspects too i don't think
you're going to cure yourself just as
you've got to take care of your body you
do also have to take care of your soul
and your mind and uh you're you're not
going to
be able to treat your whole person
because you're not just a body you're
not just a meat bag so you're not going
to be able to treat your whole person if
you ignore your mind and your soul so i
would recommend a little philosophical
and theological inquiry as well
as as well as finding a good therapist i
think that could be a good idea
from jesse hi michael
my whole life i thought it was better to
be more on the modest side and not
simply flirt to get everything you want
i'm seeing a trend here today sure use
your personality to accomplish things
but not soft core pimping themselves out
like girls who wear low-cut shirts to
get more views on their youtube channel
have i just not been using my assets as
a woman as much as i should have or is
it better to be a bit more demure
sincerely maybe i should have flirted my
way to the top
there's a difference between flirting
and
you know stripping
so
i
you think about the victorian era the
victorian area on the surface
very buttoned up but brimming with
sexuality you know and that's why you
see jokes about the victorian era a
woman would show her ankle you know and
people would you know men would start
sweating they'd be so turned on
why is that that really did sort of
happen it's because
and attraction and flirtation is not
just about our naked bodies you'll
notice most people don't look great
naked okay but this is why people wear
lingerie the point of lingerie is not
what it shows but what it covers up and
this is true i'm not suggesting you wear
lingerie in the workplace i'm saying
quite the opposite actually you can be
quite flirtatious in what you withhold
you know a
well-placed smile
or remark uh or glance even can be far
more attractive than just some hussy
parading all of her
jiggly bits you know out out for
everyone to see from chris michael
propaganda has been huge a huge theme
this week not only on your show but also
in the media more broadly reminds me of
the story of nathan hale's alleged last
words i only regret that i have but one
life to lose for my country
some say that washington used this as
propaganda and that the quote was
plagiarized from joseph addison's placo
how beautiful is death when earned by
value who would not be that youth what a
pity it is that we can die but wants to
serve our country isn't propaganda just
the mythology of the victors
sure at what end at the moment it's the
mythology about the victors and the
losers i mean there's plenty of
mythology surrounding the losers in wars
so you think in the case of the civil
war in the american south there's a
mythology that's grown up around that
too just like there is among the victors
uh you're right about nathan hale he
almost certainly never said that phrase
i think there's basically zero evidence
he ever said it
uh i think his last comment on the
scaffold was something to the effect of
it's good for officers to do what their
commander-in-chief tells them to do uh
so
i uh
yeah that that is part of the mythology
war i i don't i don't begrudge the
ukrainians or the russians for that
matter their own propaganda that's what
happens but i strongly recommend that we
who are trying to understand the
conflict and who may well be be pulled
unwittingly into this conflict we need
to be able
to
discern between propaganda and reality
and that's very very difficult when
virtually all of the media are our
propagandists themselves i'm michael
nolis the michael knowles show have a
good weekend i'll see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin